cheikh ngaido madame le ministre cherche
quand même
monsieur les secrétaires d'état cher
bruno poirson sébastien lecornu
monsieur le commissaire à l'économie
sociale et solidaire ess copier mesdames
et messieurs je voudrais tout d'abord
pour commencer te saluer nicolas je me
permets de te tutoyer de saluer ton
action je pourrais revenir sur tout ce
que tu as fait depuis pour l'éveil des
consciences en matière d'écologie
depuis les émissions de télévision grand
public à grande audience et c'était
important jusqu'à la création de la
fondation pour la nature et l'homme que
tu avais impulser et tu avais créé mais
c'est surtout ton action en tant que
ministre que je veux c'est depuis la
montée en puissance de la fiscalité
écologique et c'est un choix qui n'est
jamais facile à faire plus facile
à dire qu'à faire le choix également
difficile assumé de la fermeture des
centrales thermiques à charbon
c
savoir le département d'élection la
baraque motif étant directement
concernés je sais ce que cela représente
ensuite
difficultés de mise en oeuvre
avec
et c'est aussi la réussite
je trouve qu'on ne le dit pas assez de
la prime pour la conversion pour les
véhicules propres succès inespéré au
point que peut-être certains auraient
imaginé l'arrêté tellement ça marche
bien moi quand quelque chose marche en
matière d'écologie je veux au contraire
l'amplifient le poursuivre et l'emploi
je veux m'appuyer sur ce qui m'a donc je
m'appuierai sur ses actifs précieux que
tu as gagné pendant les quinze mois que
tu a exercé cette mesure je voudrais
saluer aussi l'action d'elisabeth bornes
ministre de transports dont on connaît
la détermination à voir mener une
réforme réussie également la réforme du
système ferroviaire de la sncf ce qui
était difficile ce qui a été fait et
c'est une excellente chose et je
voudrais aussi saluer sous leurs
réactions
doute à revoir son que sébastien lecornu
ainsi que le haut commissaire à
l'économie ce serait super c'est moins
connu
cela fait partie aussi de ce ministère
et de la transition écologique et signe
je suis donc très heureux de pouvoir
diriger cette équipe compétente et
efficace
c'est audrey enfin salué les services de
ce ministère
c'est très important vous soit ici dans
ce bâtiment soit tours à la défense
qu'il soit partout en france
toutes les régions je les connais j'ai
vu à l'oeuvre pour de nombreuses années
et je sais leur professionnalisme leur
compétence et leur engagement souvent
avec de faibles moyens
leur rendre hommage et leur dire une
comptons sur eux pour mener la politique
de transformation
c'est une transformation sur laquelle
vous
il
je suis ici parce que le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
demandé de relever ce défi d'exercer
cette lourde responsabilité
le ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire se souvenir que au
lendemain de la rentrée scolaire que
quelques jours avant la rentrée
parlementaire je n'avais pas imaginé
faire une rentrée gouvernementale mais
j'ai accepté j'ai accepté de répondre
positivement à leur demande
parce que je crois depuis toujours
l'urgence écologique est un appel à
l'urgence d'agir
je suis ici pour agir je suis ici pour
agir pour l'écologie à la méthode
détermination et persévérance dans le
temps de pluie
parler de la rentrée scolaire c'est
lorsque j'étais en classe de seconde
que j'ai adhéré à l'association nantaise
défense de l'emploi depuis que je suis
engagé je suis convaincue que l'écologie
et souvent vue comme une contrainte je
le sais souvent présentée par ceux qui
n'en veulent pas comme une contrainte
moi je suis convaincue que l'écologie
c'est une priorité
c'est une opportunité d'abord
d'amélioration des conditions de vie de
nos concitoyens
où qu'ils soient quelle que soit la
condition sociale n'en métier leur lieu
d'habitation
ce valable ici au coeur d'une grande
ville comme en banlieue ce soir dans une
grande tour hlm où que ce soit dans une
commune résidentielle et urbaine c'est
valable dans une petite ville dans une
ville moyenne comme pour quand on vit à
la campagne
l'écologie est une opportunité
d'améliorer les conditions de vie de
chacune et de chacun
c'est ma conviction profonde et 6 qui
animera mon action l'écologie est aussi
une opportunité de meilleure santé mais
je crois que la santé est au coeur des
préoccupations de nos principes
l'écologie est enfin une formidable
opportunité économique et j'entends bien
puisse faire marcher main dans la main
l'économie et l'écologie
c'est une opportunité pour créer les
activités nouvelles pour créer les
emplois pour frais de nouvelles
compétences et donc nouveaux savoir
faire aujourd'hui
mac os x ou c'est que le progrès c'est
l'héroïne
je suis convaincu d'ailleurs que c'est
ce que pensent les français
aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus les français
qu'il faut convaincre
c'est sur l'aspiration écologie des
français qu'il faut s'appuyer pour lever
les conservatismes et l'inertie
d'abord et avant tout sur cette
aspiration des français je m'appelais
c'est aussi sur les expertises et les
propositions des associations de défense
de l'environnement de protection de la
nature que jeune allure je les connais
je connais leur haut niveau d'exigence
leur esprit
souvent critique et je sais aussi le
rôle qu'elle joue partout sur le
territoire français c'est sur le savoir
faire
les entreprises engager la
transformation écologique que je
m'appuierai je sais il ya aujourd'hui
bien sur l'économie verte
on ne la valorise pas assez centaines de
milliers d'emplois que cela représente
déjà aujourd'hui et qui ne demande qu'à
se développer mais aussi des entreprises
plus traditionnelles la même façon
qu'elles engagent leur transition
numérique et leur transformation
numérique
elle engage nombreuses et elles doivent
être encore plus nombreuses demain à
s'engager dans la transition et la
transformation écologique
c'est enfin sur la volonté et
parlementaires et notamment les députés
de la majorité qui je le sais ont une
sensibilité écologique forte que je
m'appuierai je sais qu'il faut
rassembler et fédérer pour dépasser les
conservatismes
je les connais je sais existe les
défenseurs du statu quo ne voient sans
doute pas mon arrivée dans ce ministère
d'un bon oeil mais je leur dis
clairement que je serai toujours à
l'écouté des contraintes réelles
économies
social technique mais que je ne désirais
pas de la voie de la transformation
écologique voulue par les français l'or
est
élections présidentielle et législatives
le lendemain nous avons été j'étais
personnellement en tant que député sur
un programme de transformation avec le
président emmanuel macron et avec la
majorité parlementaire n'avons pas été
élus pour prolonger le statu quo pour
donner raison au tenant de merci ma
méthode sera fondée sur le dialogue
bien sûr la recherche de solutions
partagées et la décision car il ya le
temps du dialogue tant de la recherche
des solutions il ya le temps de la
justice et il ya des sujets sur lesquels
il va falloir naturellement décidé sans
appeler négocier les étapes
oui parfois mais avant c'est toujours
elle sera maintenant nous avons les
chantiers importants devant nous sur
lesquels nous avancerons rapidement
c'est le cas de la politique de
l'énergie et notamment la programmation
pluriannuelle l'énergie qui vient en
application de la loi une transition
énergétique voter en
15 il y a également la loi d'orientation
sur les transports et la mobilité
j'ai réparé par les abords sur laquelle
les parlementaires ont déjà travaillé et
qui sera aussi prochainement
alors il y aura bien sûr les enjeux de
santé environnement et bien d'autres je
ne vais pas te faire un homme
pour conclure je remercie bien sûr le
président de la république et le premier
ministre pour leur confiance je veux
aussi remercier mon épouse et ma fournit
aux lensois
il paraît qu'un des ministres le premier
l'environnement robert poujade aller dit
que c'était le ministère l'impossible
alors moi je veux en faire le ministère
iran l'écologie possible le ministère de
l'écologie positive
le ministère de l'écologie qui agit et
maintenant au travail
[Applaudissements]